[Music]
action so for most of december as we all
know adele had the top selling album in
australia followed by ed sheeran
really
wow
i didn't know that but there is a there
is a new album uh-huh that is
beating taylor swift
on the country's chart in australia
an australian artist which art which
artist do you think is psy
that's beating country genre in
australia no no no not country genre
it's beating it's beating taylor swift
it's being yeah the country in the
country's top 50 albums chart and it's
ahead of taylor swift oh not country
john in the country of australia
is beating taylor swift bts
no i don't even know what their album
hulka the weeknd
it's gotta be something that's crazy i
wonder if it's a british artist
i wonder if something ridiculous or dumb
or someone dead oh it's gotta be an old
dead thing yeah okay i'm gonna play it
for you guys are you guys ready yeah
here we go
oh my god it's just bird noise what
the moana soundtrack what
i didn't even know you were playing
something is this the start of the song
or is this the song let's just keep
going
when's the beat gonna drop
this liberian girl
this is the this is the hot single lucky
mj because it starts out like that
so this is australian bird calls
why it is number three on the entire
list in australia right now beating
taylor swift as an album or so people
are buying
that they're buying this on what
platform are they buying that well it's
the accumulated on is it because people
are using it as white noise to sleep to
work that's what i was thinking well
it's kind of nice it is nice the birds
are actually all endangered so so all
the
they collaborated yeah they all
collaborated all got together
like we are the world
this is the birds we are the world
taking turns and going up to the mic and
[ __ ] we are the world
we are the
yeah this this guy who um he works he's
a phd at charles darwin university
and he he said you know i want to
you know bring awareness to like these
birds who are endangered by releasing an
album of all their calls all the
greatest hits
also that's not a natural recording keep
layered tracks of birds
now he walked outside with all these
endangered birds together and he held
out a microphone
dude he had a whole album of endangered
birds yep how that's actually pretty
cool it's cool but like it is crazy how
it's topping taylor swift you can say
that's
that buys this album a whole [ __ ]
album right and goes oh can we play that
album on the road trip dad i bet like
isn't it bird watching pretty popular
like across especially after the
pandemic or during the years yeah like
people started bird watching bird
watching is super popular dude i saw a
[ __ ] cardinal like two days ago
it is pretty cool to see like random
wildlife i saw a [ __ ] hot bro [ __ ]
pasadena when like that that huge swarm
of like the parrots oh that's my every
day
yeah the green ones and they just like
die and [ __ ] and they're [ __ ] on the
floor they do parking lots really crazy
how'd they die i don't know
anthony's just throwing rocks at the
birds because i don't know why they're
dying i don't know why
i got a good arm
i like i like big ass birds you ever see
one of these eagles oh that's beautiful
that's a cardinal cardinal i saw this i
was in vegas and i saw this like in my
yard oh cool vegas dude got some cool
birds though yeah they got good birds
that's a football mascot birds yeah man
you know on the way to vegas you know
that [ __ ] solar panel [ __ ] that they
got yeah a lot of birds they die
the bird fryer
burnt in the sky painless death at least
there might be a moment of absolute pain
but we don't know
i like to think that they don't feel
good
people just catch them with nets at the
bottom to eat them right away that's
perfect have you guys ate a bird outside
of
duck and chicken
no i mean quail i never even tried duck
until a couple years ago you like when
you think of duck like quail eggs and
stuff don't they have like ostrich
burgers oh yeah yeah yeah that's true i
ate a uh a crow
raven really wow in [ __ ] china my dad
was like this is a delicacy a dim sum
and the bird comes like fried like this
and his chest is cut up in the meats
right there
yeah when i when i was in china they
served a pigeon in the bird cage have
you ever seen those no what's that
they'll just uh it'll be like you're
just ordering like you'd be like oh i'll
take the pigeon they bring it in an
actual bird cage and it's just a cooked
little pigeon in the cage in the cage it
was living in and the cage is edible
and then you take it out of the cage and
you put on your plate and then they take
the cage
it's super [ __ ] like performance art
dude it just tastes like a [ __ ]
chicken like a little oh okay oh i tried
quail i guess i tried quail yeah quail
coil's good duck is my favorite yeah
little quail it's pretty good i don't
like duck it tastes like [ __ ]
what
that's what i like is that what nikki
tastes like duck tastes like it's like
duck yeah did you use duck sauce nick it
tastes like sandwich sauce
barbecue
no you know when it when [ __ ] tastes
like [ __ ]
that's what duck tasted like when i
tried it
isn't that more synonymous with like the
crab stereotype yeah yeah sticky fish
i don't know boys
we're all just living the world
living the way we're living
[Laughter]
that is the only answer to give if you
had to try another bird to eat what
would you try
a bald eagle
you need a [ __ ] he's not like a
federal fence
any predator one identity
powers
yeah they taste different
eagle nuggets would be certain
i mean eagle just sounds interesting
because you just can't it's like not
allowed yeah yeah bald eagle you can't
even [ __ ] are we gonna get in trouble
for even having these premeditated
thoughts oh yeah what about eagle eggs
though is that difficult
i think that's the un-american
conversation you need to end right now
ostrich omelette let me see eagle egg
dude yeah they got i mean even in the
valley they have like ostrich burger at
like some places you know how you want
to hunt do you think you could like
[ __ ] shoot a chicken or something and
shoot a chicken i think i see we eat
chicken all the time i think the only
thing that might challenge you is
something that like one can look you in
the [ __ ] eye and you understand its
soul
bald eagles egg good whoa
summon your ego powers
i wonder what a marsupial tastes like oh
like a rat like a platypus like a otter
cause a platypus is born in an egg but
it comes out looking like a [ __ ] with
a duck bill and they have poisonous
[ __ ] things and [ __ ] they have poison
yeah do you know that you know a
platypus has [ __ ] poison in it where
what uh i don't know what the future is
what's it for i don't know that's that's
why platypuses plot of [ __ ]
i don't know um but yeah there's there
were such [ __ ] phenomenons the first
time they were discovered because they
were marsupials they're mammals they're
coming out of [ __ ] eggs but it says
that the idea that platypuses peru's
venom is false and it is falsely spread
by stupid dancers
ryan why would you spread that kind of
false information
yeah right i get a [ __ ] high out of
it
oh my god
no the platypus is one of the few living
animals to produce venom the venom is
made of venom glands that are connected
to hollow spurs on their hind legs wow
so i watch a lot of um what do you call
it those guys oh but it doesn't affect
humans
you know have you guys watched those
videos on the dancer he was talking
about
where people go into the wilderness and
they'll be like survival with nothing
but this and then like 20 days in the
wilderness and they just have to eat off
of the land or whatever but every single
time dudes catch a squirrel and then
they eat that
hands down everyone says it's [ __ ]
delicious wow i think squirrels would be
delicious really wow i don't know i just
what do you think it tastes like
probably like a rabbit similar to a
rabbit what does a rabbit taste like
kind of gamey i
what does that mean when something
tastes gamey by the way i don't even
it's not dank dark me have you ever had
uh either deer or
okay so duck is more gamey than chicken
oh so like when you get like peeking
duck it's more dark means like a denser
flavor i've had duck at like chinese
restaurants have you ever had lamb lamb
lambs how about goat oh go go go go
goats gave me yeah
gaminess meat is to me just tastes like
milky
milky
like grassy or something yeah yeah
you're right there's like a
i like that we could debate what you
tasted
it tastes sour patch kidzy
that's so funny to tell someone else you
know what's really good chinese people
do this all the time frog frog is frog
legs is good it's good but it trips me
out when i eat it frog with green onions
but especially spicy frog
it reminds me like a wing get yeah but
it's smaller did you guys ever eat
turtle
yes
dad china that's a big thing right like
like this dude was like he goes like
what do you want to order and then you
know you pass the phone and you like put
your order in with people on their
postmates they [ __ ] put turtle on
that they pass it to me and i'm
scrolling it it's nothing but turtles
and they give you and they give you the
entire turtle too yes that's what i saw
yeah you liked it it was good so how do
you eat it like crab you [ __ ] you get
a readier slider you crack the [ __ ]
open and you eat it that makes me feel
bad you use a shell like a bowl because
because of the way they cook and fry it
the shell becomes really really soft so
you can actually kind of pull you can
eat the shell uh no no i'm just saying
you could pull the meat away from it you
don't you don't traditionally eat that
part right you pulled it you pulled the
head off not the head but the like did
it go
[Laughter]
raphael is rude but tastes good
no because when i went to go visit my um
my dad's side of the family and they
they brought out like just
a stack of turtles a turtle [ __ ]
skyscraper dude i couldn't eat it i had
to go to mcdonald's i do turtles is just
it just looks it makes me feel bad
inside i always try to try things like
once just like understand well i mean
obviously there's some limitations i was
too young i was 13. i was scared of that
[ __ ] probably not going to eat a dog
ever still but um i've had like horse
before
i heard horses good horse is good i had
horses japan too american to eat a food
where it still looks like the living
thing yeah you know where like even like
you know when you go to like a filipino
party and there's a pig on the table i
don't know if you ever the chong yeah
yeah where it's like you just literally
scrape a piece of it off i like i can't
do that [ __ ] really i just can't i can't
see it i can't see it as the thing for
me fish doesn't count like i'll eat a
sardine don't give a [ __ ] i'll eat the
[ __ ] out of a fish here if it looks like
fish still i don't care but other than
that yeah i'm with you there's one thing
that i did eat that's like in that fish
category that like i don't even want to
stay on camera because i feel like
people would like it do it whales
dolphin whale i will oh i have whales
too there's a lot of that to go around
isn't there wow yeah for real no i had
it in uh uh in norway
ah
i don't know if it's even legal or
anything like that but the point is um
it was the trippiest fish i've ever
eaten trippiest fish because it's a
mammal so it it's a whale steak that
they give you so it looks exactly like
steak yeah but
everything about it it like your mind is
steak
and then you eat it and it tastes like
fish and it [ __ ] you up
that's true because when i had whale
sushi that's what i had it looked it
just looked like beef but it was purple
yeah and it was purple and then the the
best way i could explain is like it's
like filet mignon but it kind of tastes
like tuna yeah
so it's very lean was it good
it's good but you can't eat a lot of it
because i was given an actual steak so
it was like cooked like a steak it's
very rich like i say it's super rich oh
because it's so fatty honey yeah but but
the second you eat like like half of it
you're like i i can't eat this every day
for sure mine was it it tasted like the
texture of sushi with the flavor of just
iron this straight iron yeah yeah it's
very irony imagine if it was factory
farmed whale
it's just a [ __ ] gigantic-ass tank
how do you prop i gotta get out of this
business
[Music]
[Music]
you